[Music]
whether you're shopping for goods or
wanting a taste of local flavor Street
markets offer a special look inside of
the culture of a community from live
seafood on your play in Tokyo to ancient
rituals and La Paz you'll find something
different everywhere you go
here is what Street markets look like
around the world the Queen Victoria
Market is the largest open-air market in
the southern hemisphere often referred
to as Vic Market or Queen Vic the market
has been serving the city of Melbourne
since 1878 the market even hosts an
ultimate foodie tour where visitors can
learn the history of the market and
indulge in the best food it has to offer
[Music]
one is called Tsukiji market the newly
relocated toyosu market is a massive
wholesale seafood market it is most
known for the tuna auction which occurs
between 5:30 and 6:30 a.m. visitors can
watch the auction from an observation
deck the market also features fresh
produce for purchase in restaurants from
the original Tsukiji market
[Music]
the jagalchi market sells a wide variety
of seafood grab a bucket to pick out
your food on the ground floor take your
seafood to go or have it prepared into a
meal at one of the restaurants on the
second floor the market sells both a
dried and live seafood night markets
have always been prevalent in Asian
nightlife culture dating all the way
back to the Tong dynasty when the Sun
Goes Down temple street night market
comes alive with bustling visitors and
food stands cooking up a decadent Street
food take your pick from buckets of
fresh seafood or wander through the
various market stalls
[Music]
though it's it's remotely in the
westernmost part of China kashgar bazaar
is often packed with around 100,000
visitors each Sunday beyond the
souvenirs and trinkets you can find
stunning silks and rugs spices and nuts
and plenty of streets to bite into a
common saying in the areas that you can
purchase anything at kashgar bazaar
except chickens ville
[Music]
this market in Thailand is one of the
most famous floating markets in the
world located about 60 miles outside of
Bangkok damnoen saduak features longtail
boats that drift along the market
visitors can purchase fresh produce
souvenirs and an array of snacks the
Malik gut flower market is one of the
biggest flower markets in Asia flowers
could sell out as early as noon so
vendors start their days at 4 a.m.
blocks of ice are used to keep the
flowers fresh the market boasts an array
of colorful flowers including roses
jasmine and marigolds which are all used
to make mullahs or garland mullahs are
commonly used for religious rituals
ceremonies and as decoration for houses
roads and cities discover thousands of
spices at the dubai spice souk shoppers
can haggle for herbs and dried fruits
and flowers and even natural deodorant
[Music]
Grand Bazaar is one of the biggest and
oldest covered markets in the world
dating back to the 15th century once a
staple of the Ottoman Empire the market
today houses over four thousand shops
wander through the maze of hallways or
decadent Turkish streets colorful
textiles and mosaic lamps light up the
halls authentic handmade Turkish rugs
are a great souvenir the yzma Loski
market is a hidden treasure tucked
inside the izmailovo kremlin the market
is the ultimate stop for authentic
Russian treats and souvenirs like the
famous matryoshka doll Christmas markets
are a European staple during the
holidays Prague hosts its Christmas
markets from the end of November to the
beginning of January with the main
markets held in Old Town Square and
Wenceslas Square the market is aligned
with food stalls offering small bites
like roasted chestnuts chips on a stick
and chimney cake known as Trudel neck
visitors can also warm up with a cup of
mulled wine and shop handmade trinkets
and souvenirs
[Music]
Venetians rely on the rialto market for
their fruits vegetables and other goods
each day for seafood lovers the FISC
area offers up some of the freshest
secretos in Venice many of which are
purchased by restaurants in the area
[Music]
what was once a pig market in 1470 is
now a thriving corner of Barcelona known
as mercado de la boqueria sometimes
referred to as the heart of the city the
market features an array of quality
meats cheeses produce and more
[Music]
by day you can find an array of goods
and even snake charmers at djemaa el-fna
by night the square lights up with food
stands serving authentic Moroccan
cuisine
[Music]
better peso offers fruits vegetables and
medicinal herbs from the rainforests it
also hosts the acai fair where acai is
sold and consumed in its natural form
[Music]
you can find potions spells and
medicinal goods at this bolivian market
the witches market sells goods based on
traditional medicines and rituals the
markets most notable item is a dried
llama foetus which is said to bring good
luck and protection
[Music]
you'll find vendors selling their
homegrown and handcrafted goods in the
bustling Castries market the market was
originally built in 1891 to improve the
town and has since become the largest
open-air market in the area shop the
various stalls or soak up the vibrant
cast Racine
[Music]
chichi Gustin tango is one of
Guatemala's most vibrant markets vendors
sell colorful textiles fresh produce and
an abundance of flowers sold on the
steps of the church also called chichi
the market is only open on Thursdays and
Saturdays
since rowdy Abbas Stowe is one of the
largest wholesale markets in the world
with over 2,000 businesses covering over
800 acres 30 thousand tons of
merchandise go through the market each
day the market is lined with colorful
fruits and vegetables many of which make
their way into hundreds of restaurants
and food stands in the city each day
[Music]
Pike Place Market is a staple in the
Pacific Northwest the market has been
serving the community since in 1907
colorful produce handmade pasta and
plenty of fish sold by local fish
mongers are available each day Pike
Place Fish Market is best known for its
tradition at tossing customers orders
across the shopping area watch as they
toss the fish around or try catching
your own
[Music]
New York City is a melting pot of food
innovation influenced by multiple
cultures all over the city glassy food
halls with dozens of options are popping
up like the Canal Street Market some
options include so-called food mash-ups
like sushi burritos
[Music]
you